1000 dollar ist weg da hast du mir leid
ich habe mir auf amazon bestellt aber
der hat aufgrund von corona
lieferprobleme und deswegen müssen wir
leider heute noch mal ohne ein trecker
die neue bi wurde to how to handle
schauen wir müssen uns nur zusammen
reichen
wir sind da wachsen ja wenn uns
beherrscht worum geht's und wie breit
der letzten episode haben sich francesca
und harry ja wieder einmal viel viel
viel besser verstanden
deswegen hatte lara also dieser roboter
ist dieser schau der alles überwacht
zudem gesagt hier kriegt grünes licht
ihr dürft ihr die private suite würden 8
ich bin gespannt wie viele regeln da
jetzt gebrochen werden alters schon
schön die chance für harry und sein als
in den ultimativen test zu bestehen
alter das ist genau so wie es bei mir in
hamburg machen werde
nur halt ohne francesca aber von stets
ganz normales foul keine nacht zu zweit
müssen sich leider trotz neuer regeln
halten die schaffen das sehr gut wir
sind von den stich ja ich wusste
ich wusste es war so klar es war einfach
so klar sparen uns für ihre songs auf
ich habe vollstes vertrauen in die
beiden sei kein grund zur
ich hatte
wirklich vertraulich
wirklich
wirklich gedacht ich schaffe ich war
wieder enttäuscht beim kampf kakerlaken
was ist eine kampfstarke das war's sagt
man das war's mit allen szenen die wir
zu sehen bekommen habe ich bin echt
gespannt was da jetzt an strafen auf die
leute zu gott verdammt ich wette die
haben kohle raus gehauen
ich bin gespannt muss ich für ein zimmer
zahlen dass ich nicht genutzt habe
stimmt ja eigentlich für krasse
dehnungsstreifen überall
habe ich nicht aber ich habe auch keine
muskeln terry war echt scharf drauf mal
mit francesca allein zu sein
hey ich rechne mit der maximalstrafe hat
war merkte da hat er auf dem boden
geschlafen letzten acht
sk
nämlich wissen wie viel geld die frau
war am letzten abend war magisch
wir fanden beide das ist der richtige
schritt für unsere beziehung war und ich
konnte ich nicht zurückhalten
wer hätte gedacht dass ein paar minuten
alles ändern kann
um was geht es jetzt gerade was hatten
die jetzt ich kümmere mich um deren
liebesleben viel mehr als über eigene
ich traurig wie mein leben
wir sind jetzt pleite es würde mich
wundern nicht wartet ab bis ihr den
anderen beichten müsst was ihr getan
habt ja erst das ist dieser neue ricoh
ne
glaubt mir einfach nicht
was namen angeht ich bin da ganz
schlecht drittmittel zu merken ich finde
preis körperlich einfach nicht anziehen
ich fühle mich schlecht deswegen aber
ich kann es nicht ändern
okay da wird wohl abschreiben reden
müssen das wird spannend
ich habe versucht madison kennenzulernen
es gibt hier einfach niemanden
verbessern kannst du dich mit hayley
treffen
aber ich darf das passt auch nicht mit 4
und hayley sind beide so kandidaten die
einfach nie den perfekten partner finden
würden also spaß also spaß
oh mein gott ich sie kann noch laufen
[Musik]
bin so gespannt
was die der gruppe an geld gekostet
haben wir haben gewartet und übers leben
geregelt hatte nannte jung schön und
baut jetzt das geld verballert gab mir
ja leider nicht aber hier ist also wenn
mit mandaten
[Applaus]
es hat spaß gemacht alles klar
ksta
das ist für mich gerade überhaupt nicht
emotional belastenden linie
wir fanden es war der richtige zeit wie
sind sie haben eine stärkere verbindung
gut vergleichen
die sache ist könnt ihr euch noch an die
erste oder zweite folge erinnern ich
weiß nicht mehr genau wann der
stattgefunden hat allerdings auf jeden
fall wo sich harry und francesca geküsst
haben
und alle sind begeistert kann
ausgerastet und jetzt hatten sie einfach
sein
was ein viel größerer film ist was das
geld angeht und ist alle sind so voll
süßer neuer zeitpunkt war genau richtig
die doppel moralisch seid ihr denn alle
halo für euer preisgeld war das richtig
schlecht ja wie lang konntest du ja
schrecklich es war schrecklich
zehn sekunden dollarzeichen hatte das
breiteste grinsen im gesicht von spar
british mehr die regel zum euch ist in
keiner sauer darüber wie viel geld ihr
verloren hast ja klein reden hält der
buchhalter natürliche verwarf und uns
viele nicht so richtig schön in la
funktion gibt ja irgendwie auf dem
mädchen steht und es läuft sogar ein
paar wochen oder so mandated oder keine
ahnung was und irgendwann traut man sich
also den ersten schritt machen und man
küsst an
und dann ist es so richtig so beide
haben lust darauf beide sind verliebt
das ist das schönste gefühl der welt
real talk das ist das schönste gefühl
wenn wenn das dann klappt hat es bei mir
noch nie ich hoffe ich finde das auch
[Musik]
vielleicht
ich glaube aber eher mit reifen statt
mit seinem skoda als er nämlich
der preis und jetzt kommt's zum gespräch
das wird nicht gut enden glaube ich kann
alles gut
wir müssen reden ganz blöd
wo wir doch schon sitzt dann doch nicht
nein sagen meine liebe lampe ich wollte
nur sagen dass du ein echter gentleman
willst ich finde du bist ein sehr netter
kerl aber ich sehe uns einfach nur
freundschaften und anspringen preis ins
meer und tochter wahrscheinlich am
liebsten gar nicht mehr wo ich denke was
ich will und was ich brauche sind zwei
verschiedene dinge
ok und mit curry hat es sofort klick
gemacht
wie heißt er corrie rico aber gar nicht
so weit weg aber ich kann unsere lampe
da auf jeden fall verstehen meine lieben
freunde und zwar es ist halt oft so dass
wenn man halt noch nicht so richtig
erfahren ist was liebe angeht und
beziehungen angeht dass man sich oft
erst für dinge entscheidet die nur das
kurzfristige sind aus einem halt
kurzfristig glücklich macht und was man
langfristig braucht das erkennt man
meistens eher später wenn es zu spät ist
also ich kann es verstehen dass sie hier
eine verbindung sucht und ich meine
lampe ohne verbindung leuchtet natürlich
auch nicht aber keine sorge
du solltest das tun was du möchtest
erwachsen wer erwachsen sondern vorher
nicht ehrlich gesagt nicht gerechnet und
ich hoffe auch dass die lampe jetzt
vielleicht irgendwie was mit diesem
rekord anfang der woche war und dann
vielleicht noch nachfolge märkten wird
ja er ist doch nichts für mich ich habe
den sinn der sendung verstanden und ich
versuche mit preis ab vielleicht ist ja
auch cool
wir werden zusehen kann man nie und
fische mehr aber das weißt du sicher
immerhin wusste auf einem boot
[Musik]
wow
das wird immer besser mit den worten was
auch immer besser wird meine lieben
freunde das merchandising lukas und geht
nicht da sind der 15 uhr jetzt wird es
richtig ernst wurde letzte nacht in der
private suite auf den kopf gehauen müll
das wird sicher wehtun
ok jetzt wird spannend jetzt schon jeder
bescheid was franziska und harry ihr
seid die ersten die im resort & care
überraschung
ich kann schon sehen wie erinnerlich
richtig anfängt wütend zu werden das ist
der bisher gravierend der regelverstoß
und verlangt eine heftige strafe wie
teuer ist wenn ein chor aus 3000 kostet
bestimmt
stimmen wenn das waren relation setzen
kurz 3000 also ich rate jetzt meine
lieben freunde wieder rate show wer wird
millionär musik ist schon wieder an
schreibt mir jetzt in die kommentare was
ihr denkt wie teuer dieser sex gewesen
ist von harry und francesca würde sagen
12.000
12.000 euro würde ich sagen ja ein box
aus sagt einfach 20.000 dollar anzieht
1000 dollar
das sind 20.000 cheeseburger
durch die heutige episode luca reagiert
auf die hände jetzt allerdings auch bei
ihnen meine lieben freunde bezeugen mal
wieder gefallen hat dann einen darunter
medienschaffende 40.000 leicas wirklich
übertrieben freundin wird mit zeigen
euch gefällt diese serie weiterhin und
ich solle mir auch die letzten zwei
folgen noch anschauen und wenn er noch
kein abonnent von meinem kanal sei dann
klickt hier oben gerne auf den smiley
drauf dann werdet ihr teil der lumension
und verpasst keine zukünftigen videos
von mir mehr wenn ihr dieses t shirt
gefeiert und am 20
17.15 uhr heinz kaufen wollt dann schaut
und meinestadt.de vorbei dort geht es
dann nämlich lounge und hier ist meine
letzte reaction verlegen die vor drei
tagen online kam also schaut euch das
allemal
[Musik]